right you just knocked off the reigning
defending
national champions what is this moment
like for you right now
oh man it's awesome it's awesome uh
huge credit to you know just the bench
uh i don't know if you can see it on tv
but man that energy was amazing um
and our teammates you know following the
game plan you know we really executed
especially on the defensive end
you said after the mac championship that
the first person you thought of was your
mom
i have to imagine that you're thinking
of her right now as well
when i seen three two one that's all i
was thinking about
yeah i hope she's proud i hope she's
proud
jason this is a team that jeff bulls
said he wanted to get back to the place
he had been
in the ncaa tournament what message are
you sending now
to creighton with this performance
against virginia
hope you know we're going to compete no
matter who we're playing we're going to
compete every single possession
um we're going to bring great energy and
we're going to have fun you know 1
through 15 we all just have fun tonight
it shows out on the floor jason
congratulations go celebrate with your
teammates thank you so much